you still speak to him right Roxanna why
I have not spoken to him and in quite
some time and as you know Howard I've
even come on and done a radio interview
with you since I had dated Charlie I had
spoke nothing but positive things about
Charlie I have never said a negative
thing I have never torn him apart in any
way but I am so upset and that I could I
couldn't be more I'm so shaking I have
been crying that to think that I that
someone could do that to me were you in
love with Charlie Sheen
I loved him yes he was my boyfriend you
didn't look at it like hey this is sort
of like I'm the porn star like it was
like a boyfriend/girlfriend relationship
to you I left the industry for him and I
never went back he just admitted right
in that interview that that is the the
tiger blood time that's when I was with
him I was living with him and we were
sleeping together every single night and
never said a word never said anything
I'm briefer you Aibileen he told me I'm
clean I'm clean and I made the same
mistake that a lot of people do you know
I trusted them